le variateur le variant delta marion
delta progresse il progresse même très
rapidement après alpha bêta et gamma
voici delta on ne parle presque que de
lui et pour cause plus contagieux bien
plus transmissible ce variant du sart
skov deux fait des ravages en inde en
russie et s'installe en france
al'approche des vacances d'été il
inquiète le gouvernement et rebat les
cartes de l'épidémie alors que le rythme
de vaccination ralentit fortement en
quoi le variant delta est il différent
des précédents variant peut-on sauver
l'été et éviter une quatrième vague à la
rentrée réponse dans facture voici donc
delta apparu en inde à la fin de l'année
2020 et maintenant prénommé delta comme
la quatrième lettre de l'alphabet grec
delta est classé variant préoccupant par
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
il est donc surveiller de très près et
ce pour plusieurs raisons
petit tour d'horizon de ces
caractéristiques
s'il a réussi à s'installer en france
aussi rapidement depuis avril 2021
c'est un peu car d'elda a gagné une
sorte de course aux variants grâce à son
important taux de transmissibilité
il a gagné les compétitions en inde puis
il est arrivé en grande-bretagne puis
ensuite il est arrivé au portugal puis
en russie est maintenant en europe
souvenez vous il y a un an et demi au
tout début de l'épidémie on parlait
beaucoup du r 0 le taux de reproduction
du virus celui de la souche originel du
sart skov 2 qui a aimé
orhan oscillait entre 2 et 3 c'est à
dire qu'une personne infectée en
infecter à 100 pour environ 2 ou 3 mai
pour le variant delta on pense
aujourd'hui par des calculs
mathématiques
le héros est supérieure à 5 bien
supérieur peut être le double de cette
souche originel de vaux ain et il n'est
pas impossible que le r0 du brillant
delta soi même à ses supérieurs
peut-être de 6 voire certains disent de
8 c'est une donnée assez théorique
l'issue de la modélisation mathématique
mais quand on voit les difficultés que
l'on a à contrer la progression de ce
variant là c'est compatible avec un air
zéro qui serait de 5 2 6 gardons à
l'esprit que le nombre de personnes que
l'on insectes des plans bien évidemment
des mesures mises en place à ce
moment-là confinement strict ou pas
fermeture des commerces couvre-feu port
du masque ou encore distanciation
sociale mais il n'empêche que selon le
centre européen de prévention et de
contrôle des maladies
le variant delta et 40 à 60% plus
transmissible que le variant britannique
lui même bien plus transmissible que la
souche originel seconde inquiétude c'est
la virulence du variant c'est à dire sa
capacité à induire une infection grave
ou pas l'inde a eu une vague qu'on a
bien vu dévastatrice avec un grand
nombre de décès la russie connaît aussi
aujourd'hui un très grand nombre de
décès avec ce variant delta clairement
en tout cas ça n'est pas un variant
bénin en revanche au royaume uni on ne
voit pas un excès de mortalité
aujourd'hui avec cette souche
donc on a l'impression que probablement
les personnes vaccinées sont bien
protégés contre la virulence des tirs
contre les complications contre la
sévérité liées à l'infection ce qui
semble différent tout cas c'est que sa
charge virale est bien plus élevée que
celle des précédents va rien donc vous
auriez plus de copies de virus dans
votre gorge quand vous êtes infecté vos
aérosols serait plus chargées en copie
de virus et quand vous êtes dans un
espace clos confiné mal ventilée avec
beaucoup de monde qu'ils allaient
émettre ces aérosols qui a plus de
copies de virus dans l'atmosphère la
caractéristique qui inquiète donc c'est
la capacité du delta à pénétrer les
cellules humaines en raison des
mutations portant sur ce qu'on appelle
la protéine spykee c'est à dire celle
qui va s'accrocher qui est le trousseau
de clés on peut dire
qui permettent au virus d'entrer dans la
cellule si la clé est un petit peu plus
adapté encore à nos cellules
alors le virus peut être tu
transmissibles ce qui semble acquis
c'est en tout cas que la solution la
plus efficace contre ce delta est bien
seul vaccin l'approchent vaccinale reste
une approche extrêmement efficace et ici
on voit bien que c'est vraiment la
solution il faut atteindre des
couvertures de la population qui sont
autour de 80% voire plus
en fait ça va dépendre aussi de à quel
point on arrive à vacciner les
populations plus jeunes a évoqué
notamment la vaccination des enfants des
adolescents
à ce stade les vaccins autorisés par
l'union européenne reste bien efficace
contre le variant réduisent fortement
les risques d'hospitalisation et de
formes graves reste un scénario
difficile qui pourrait bien provoquer
une quatrième vague et la saturation des
hôpitaux d'ici la rentrée
selon le centre européen des maladies
70% des nouvelles infections seront dus
au delta dans l'union européenne d'ici
début août et 90% d'ici la fin de l'été
c'est la couverture vaccinale n'augmente
donc pas en france au cours de l'été
alors plus le variant sera majoritaire
plus il fera de dégâts au sein des
catégories de personnes vulnérables non
vaccinés si on n'est pas à 90 voire 100
% de couverture des personnes les plus à
risque ces personnes vont être très à
risque d'être hospitalisée et donc on va
voir de nouvelles hospitalisations si on
a un virus qui circule encore beaucoup
or début juillet seulement 63 % des plus
de 50 ans en france et est entièrement
vacciner sachant que windows protège
bien m'en efficacement que deux doses
cette bague que l'on voit au royaume uni
pourrait finir par se propager dans le
petit pourcentage restant de gens peu
immunisée chez les personnes très âgées
son royaume uni ou en israël meilleur ou
le variant delta aussi s'implante
on voit bien que il ne fait pas les
ravages qu'il a fait en inde et qu'il
fait actuellement en russie grande
différence entre ces pays c'est que
israël ou le royaume uni sont très
vacciner ce qui rejoint les
modélisations et les recommandations de
l'institut pasteur qui affirme bien que
parmi toutes les mesures étudiées la
vaccination des non vaccinés
et elle approche la plus efficace pour
contrôler l'épidémie la situation des
enfants et des adolescents devant être
considérés avec particulièrement
d'attention compter sur les littératures
elle en se passant du vaccin
je vais faire un grave contresens et un
grand danger de santé publique et un
grand danger pour être liberté tout
simplement si quand même pas
complètement délirant de penser à une
vaccination obligatoire pour du
personnel soignant puisque c'est déjà le
cas sur d'autres vaccinations comme
l'hépatite b par exemple une autre piste
selon antoine flahault alors que le taux
de circulation du virus est assez faible
en france en ce moment c'est qu'il
faudrait en profiter pour être plus
ambitieux dans notre stratégie de
criblage des tests pcr
autrement dit l'analyse des tests pour
identifier une mutation sur un virus
en l'occurrence ici les yeux 484 qu est
l 452 m
ce qui était impossible lorsque l'on
détecté plus de 30 mille cas par jour
cette stratégie appliquée avec beaucoup
beaucoup de succès par les japonais est
une stratégie qui est très proactive
utilise beaucoup ce qu'on appelle le
rétro tu racing qui est peut-être aidé
aujourd'hui par le séquençage très
systématique des souches
quand on a deux trois mille cas par jour
on doit pouvoir dans un pays comme la
france
avoir une capacité de séquençage de deux
ou trois mines souche très exhaustive
renoncer à un séquençage exhaustif c'est
renoncer probablement à une
identification de toutes les chaînes de
transmission sur le territoire
simplement en identifiant toutes les
chaînes de transmission sans aucune
exception qu'on peut arriver à les
démanteler
or aujourd'hui en france seule la moitié
des tests font l'objet d'un séquençage
et la majorité d'entre eux font bien
apparaître la mutation correspondant à
celle de variants delta
[Musique]